well if you have flown recently you may
have encountered some delays or even
cancellations thank you for joining us
at six
i'm christian casadas and i'm denise
valdez so we are learning it's not just
one issue
it's staffing shortages there's weather
issues travelers are frustrated at
airports
not only here but across the country
that's right well the most recent
problem this week
stems from cancellations and delays
associated with spirit airlines
joe muller is now live at mccarran
airport to tell us when the problems
could
possibly be resolved joe
christian spirit airlines is apologizing
for so many cancellations and they say a
lot of these issues should be resolved
by tomorrow take a look at the
arrival and departure board here there's
a lot less cancellations this evening
than there was earlier today
many people have been waiting here
wondering if they will ever get to their
destination
a lot of tension a lot of tension
another day of cancellations means
another day of frustration
just being left in the dark we don't
know if we're gonna get refunded we
don't know if we're going to
when's the next flight no idea and you
know we
all got to work we all have jobs at 8 30
this morning i get a text saying your
flight has been canceled
i'm like you got to be kidding me this
week problems in the skies many airlines
with above normal cancellations
speared airlines scrubbing hundreds of
flights come to the
leave on monday flight been canceled
four time i rescheduled it four times
josephina bell is trying to get to
orlando they'll be the last trip i've
ever flight with spirit
they don't gotta be me getting on their
airplanes the spirit tells us quote
we've dealt with overlapping operational
challenges including weather system
outages and staffing shortages
that cause widespread irregularities in
our operation and impacted crew
scheduling
spirit expects the cancellations to drop
by thursday all this could tell you
i'm so sorry american airlines dealt
with a string of cancellations earlier
this week
they blamed a storm in dallas causing a
wave of problems
meanwhile spirit passengers are
considering other options can they give
me an option to get home because we you
know
kids have school have work obviously we
need to get home
now back out here live we're taking
another look at the arrival board there
a lot less cancellations than we saw
earlier today other complaints from
travelers on other airlines is delays
and
gates and baggage issues ground crews
just hustling to keep up with the demand
to fly so if you are planning to fly
it's a good idea
to factor patients and to check your
flight status before you head here to
mccarran
reporting live at mccarran this evening
joe mohler 8 news now